estamos de regreso con winston y él se
afeitó zoom y ceja porque no le gustaba
mucho pero ahora winston va a ir a una
fiesta y quiere un sombrero para la
fiesta
que podríamos usar para hacer un
sombrero de fiesta bueno quiero
mostrarles cómo usar la función traen
gol porque no lo habíamos usado antes
así que vamos a tratar de hacer un
sombrero desde un triángulo voy a
arrastrar el triángulo aquí arriba y se
dibuja un triángulo amarillo porque
tenemos esta función fill que está
configurada como amarillo y hace que
estas dos cosas sean amarillas pero
ahora es confuso realmente ver la
diferencia entre la elipse y el
triángulo así que voy a arrastrar otra
función film y seleccionar un color de
fiesta la función trangol se ve un poco
intimidante porque tiene seis parámetros
aquí y antes solo manejamos cuatro
parámetros ahora estos parámetros como
pueden ver arriba son x 1 y 1 x 2 y 2 y
x 3 y 7 3 en realidad qué significa esto
son los tres pares de coordenadas de
cada punto del triángulo
este punto este punto y este punto no es
tan obvio cuando los ven saber
exactamente cuál coordenada es cual
punto así que tienen que mirar los
números y luego mirar aquí arriba y
tratar de entenderlo
el primero es 2020 y este punto que está
aquí parece exactamente como el punto
2020 porque está 20 píxeles hacia la
derecha y 20 píxeles abajo este es 100
100 bueno parece que es este punto que
está aquí 100 píxeles a la derecha y 100
píxeles hacia abajo y este otro que es
el punto que queda 250 50 son 250
píxeles desde la izquierda y 50 píxeles
hacia abajo así que estas son nuestras
coordenadas si queremos cambiar nuestro
triángulo para ponerlo en un lugar
diferente
necesitamos imaginarnos cuál de las
coordenadas tenemos que cambiar y por
cuánto o simplemente jugar con los
números voy a hacer un sombrero de
fiesta y pienso que este punto está en
un buen lugar así que voy a dejar el
punto 100 100 así como está pero este
punto que está aquí lo tenemos que mover
hacia acá eso significa que tenemos que
cambiar la equis porque ésta es
la dirección de x así que voy aquí y
aumentó su tamaño ok se ve bien ahora
voy a mover este punto más abajo y un
poco hacia afuera vamos a ver vamos
hacia abajo
y luego quiero que sea más ancho
se ve bien solo voy a mover esta x un
poco
hermoso ahora tenemos un sombrero de
fiesta
si la función traen go es confusa tiene
muchos números y tienes que jugar con
ellos una vez más esta es una situación
en la que me encanta hacer mi dibujo
primero en un papel y entenderlo pero
también pueden sentarse y jugar con los
números en la pantalla una vez que hayan
hecho algunos triángulos van a ser
expertos en coordenadas logren lo